[Music]
the most powerful unlv volleyball team
in history is dancing on easter
the undefeated rebels found out they
will be playing illinois state in omaha
nebraska
in round one of the ncaa tournament it
is remarkable to just make it
but no one said anything about these
ladies being done
they are the trophy raising rebels
cascaded in confetti
and highlighted in history it wasn't
just a cinderella story we put in the
time and the effort to get to this
moment the unlv volleyball story is
about perfection
in a pandemic even though they had their
fall season pushed to the spring
were paused by kovitt and unallowed to
play in front of fans
the rebels finished a flawless 12-0
i think through all that adversity just
how they they're relentless and they're
very
they persevere and they able to kind of
just like okay what's next
and that part's really special coach don
sullivan leads the conference in
composure
but her team goes for the kill
until this year the program had never
won a mountain west title
but these ladies bring the hammer just
looking back at our freshman year i mean
we were bottom of the conference 8-23
overall like
basically the laughingstock so basically
starting from the bottom and now we're
number one
the ncaa tournament selection show
served no drama
only a dream unlv is going to the dance
watching all these players go through it
with ncaa tournament march madness i
mean seeing all the confetti the hats
the shirts that just got us
even more hyped but this is something
i've been watching since i've been a
little girl finally to be on that big
stage and compete at that high of a
level is
something i've always dreamed 48 teams
made it to omaha here
come the rebels